Hey everybody. Uh, it's a podcast. It's smart lists and you have hosts, Sean, Will, Jason. Here comes here. It comes here. Oh yeah. Welcome to smart. You know I said to Scotty yesterday, I said, you know these... Can we guess?
大家好。呃，这是一个播客。这是《SmartLess》，我是主持人肖恩、威尔、杰森。来啦，来啦，来啦。哦，对。欢迎来到Smart。你知道我昨天对斯科特说……我当时说，你知道这些……我们能猜到吗？
Can we guess what you said to Scotty yesterday? Well, you go first, I'll go second. Did you touch my sprinkles? Jay do you have a guess? I'm still writing it but it's it's somewhere in the Star Wars Star Trek fight canon you know. No I said to him concept cars they... Should we put a loveseat in the toilet? they... Should we put a loveseat in the toilet? No, I said concept cars are such a waste of time because they're such a tease. Like, they're these really cool cars and they never make them.
我们能猜到你昨天对斯科特说了什么吗？好吧，你先来，我第二个。你摸我的糖屑了吗？杰伊，你有头绪吗？我还在写，但它大概属于《星球大战》或《星际迷航》的争论范畴吧。不，我对他说的是概念车……我们应该在马桶上放一张双人沙发吗？他们……我们应该在马桶上放一张双人沙发吗？不，我说概念车太浪费时间了，因为它们太像恶作剧了。就像，这些车真的很酷，但他们从来不量产。
It's like, why don't they just make them? Sometimes they do and they take pieces of them. I feel like that Tesla super truck, whatever the hell it is, it looks like an absolute joke rolling around the roads. Oh, you mean the douche identifier? Douche is you guys. We had a feeling you were a dick and now it's confirmed.
就像是，他们为什么不直接生产呢？有时候他们会生产，并且会采用其中的一些零件。我觉得那个特斯拉超级卡车，不管到底是个什么鬼东西，在路上开起来就像是个绝对的笑话。哦，你是说混蛋识别器？混蛋就是你们。我们有一种预感，你是个混蛋，现在证实了。
Yeah, it looks like a silver 80s tank or something. I love it. It's so distracting. I love it because you do get to see, you're like, where are all the douche bags? There they are, there's one there, then you can just stay away. It does look like a concept car,
对，它看起来像一个银色的80年代坦克什么的。我超爱。太让人分心了。我喜欢它是为了能让你看到，你会想，所有混蛋都在哪儿？哦，在那儿呢，那边有一个，然后你就能离他们远点。它看起来确实像一辆概念车，
and then they went to production on it. It's like, oh. It's the dumbest. But some of the concept cars that all these companies make, they're so cool. And then you're like, well, okay, well, where do you get one of those? And they never make them.
然后他们还真把这车给量产了。简直是，哦。太蠢了。但这些公司制造的一些概念车，它们太酷了。然后你就会想，好吧，好吧，上哪儿能买到一辆那种车？结果他们根本不量产。
It's like couture. Oh, sorry, Jason, go ahead. Well, so what where do you get one of those? And they never make them. Sure. It's like couture. It's like a tea. Oh, sorry, Jason, go ahead. Well, so what they do in the fashion world is they'll go ahead and they'll make stuff just for the fashion show. This Henley, for instance, can't be found. Jason, I'm gonna, and Will, please come by,
就像高级时装。哦，抱歉，杰森，你接着说。好吧，所以……上哪儿能买到一辆那种车？结果他们根本不量产。当然。就像高级时装。就像一个茶。哦，抱歉，杰森，你接着说。好吧，所以他们在时尚界所做的是，他们会专门为时装秀制作一些衣服。比如这件亨利衫，就买不到。杰森，我打算，威尔，请也过来，
but you're gonna be in New York. Amanda and Maple are coming over for dinner next week. What? Wow. Yeah. dinner next week. What? Wow. Yeah. God damn it. What night? Wednesday, come over.
但你要去纽约。阿曼达和梅普尔下周要来家里吃晚饭。什么？哇。对。下周吃晚饭。什么？哇。对。该死。哪天？周三，过来。
I'll be gone by then. Wonderful, wonderful. Jay, would you say you're at the cutting edge of fashion, by the way, because I noticed you wearing some rag and bone jeans, which reminded me of 2011, and I thought, here's my guy. Listen, things are great back here in 2011. Anyway, listen, we could do this forever all day
到那时我都已经走了。太棒了，太棒了。杰伊，顺便问一下，你会说自己走在时尚的前沿吗，因为我注意到你穿着几条Rag & Bone牛仔裤，这让我想起了2011年，我想，这才是我的哥们儿。听着，2011年的日子可真不错。总之，听着，我们可以一整天都这样聊下去，
and I'm sure our guest is just riveted by what we're saying. I can tell you something that I am. I'm riveted when she's performing. I am riveted and by riveted, I mean generally laughing the entire time. I think it's so rare when, or it's so special when a performer comes along That just kind of constant every time you see them they exceed expectations And then they just surprise you with their comedy
而且我敢sure我们的嘉宾一定对我们的言论入迷极了。我可以告诉你一件事，我是的。当她表演时，我是如此入迷。我太入迷了，说到入迷，我的意思是整场演出我基本上都在从头笑到尾。我觉得当一个表演者出现时是多么罕见，或者说多么特别，他们那种始终如一的表现，每次你看到他们，他们都会超出预期，然后他们总能用喜剧给你带来惊喜。
She is somebody who makes you laugh from moment one and then the next it's not Cher And she makes you laugh in ways that you're like an end She has that unique thing also of every time you hear a joke not only you're laughing you're thinking I can't believe I didn't think of that. It's so brilliant and it's and it's and she keeps topping herself She's had a million specials. She had a new special. Sorry. What color is her hair? Well She has a new special that just came out on HBO Max or whatever they call it on May 11th but she really, really rocked herself this year in the ultimate roast of Tom Brady. You guys, it's the none other than the most hilarious Nikki Glaser.
她是一个能让你从头笑到尾的人，而且接下来……她可不是雪儿。她能让你笑得前仰后合，让你觉得……而且她还有那种独特的魅力，就是每次你听到一个笑话，不仅在笑，你还会想：我简直不敢相信自己怎么没想到这个。太绝了，而且，她一直在不断超越自己。她有过一百万场专场演出。她有一个新专场……抱歉。她头发是什么颜色的？好吧，她有一个新专场刚刚在HBO Max还是他们现在叫什么的地方上线，就在5月11日，但她今年在汤姆·布雷迪终极吐槽大会上真的彻底炸翻了。各位，她就是大名鼎鼎、最搞笑的尼基·格拉泽。
Oh my gosh. Nikki Glaser. There she is. Good morning. Hi guys. Wait, are you in the back of a coffee shop? Where are you? I'm at the Comedy Store podcast studio.
哦天哪。尼基·格拉泽。她在那儿。早安。嗨，各位。等等，你在咖啡馆的后面吗？你在哪儿？我在喜剧商店播客工作室。
Truly? I'm visiting LA and I wasn't going to fuck around with you guys. I wasn't going to trust my wifi at my hotel. I needed like a real studio. This is the real deal. You're not an Angelino? No, I live in St. Louis. So you moved back to St. Louis full time?
真的吗？我来洛杉矶访问，我可不想跟你们瞎胡闹。我才不信我酒店的wifi呢。我需要一个真正的工作室。这才是来真的。你不是洛杉矶人吗？不，我住在圣路易斯。所以你全职搬回圣路易斯了？
I did, I did. I went back during COVID just to hang out with my parents and my family, and then it lifted and I was just like, no one even knows I'm here. I can just go to LA and people in LA think I'm in New York and people in New York think I'm in LA. Isn't the crime rate huge there?
是的，是的。我在新冠疫情期间搬回去的，只是为了陪陪我父母和家人，然后疫情解封了，我就想，甚至没人知道我在。我可以去洛杉矶，洛杉矶的人以为我在纽约，纽约的人以为我在洛杉矶。那里的犯罪率不是很高吗？
Yeah, in certain parts. Alright, wonderful. Oh, wait, Sean, like, combing the internet for... I just read that about St. Louis. We have the highest crime, but it's really... That can't be true. That's got to be like a per capita qualifier. Well, Nikki, what's the number one crime that's going on there?
对，在某些地方。好吧，太棒了。哦，等等，肖恩，就像在互联网上搜索……我刚读到关于圣路易斯的报道。我们的犯罪率最高，但其实……那不可能是真的。那一定是有某种按人均计算的限定条件。好吧，尼基，那儿最主要的犯罪是什么？
Probably carjackings and murder. Carjackings and murder. Well, I guess that's going on there? Probably carjackings and murder. Carjackings and murder. Well, I guess that's alarming. It's not errors at third base. You know, you got that Nolan Ariando over there. You know, good for you. Yeah, but you just got to avoid parts of town. But it's a segregated city.
可能是劫车和谋杀。劫车和谋杀。好吧，我猜那确实挺让人担忧的？可能也就是劫车和谋杀。劫车和谋杀。好吧，我猜那确实挺让人担忧的。不是三垒失误。你知道，你们那边还有那个诺兰·阿雷纳多呢。你知道，那挺好的。对，但你只要避开城里的某些地方就行了。但这是一座被隔离的城市。
It's not the greatest for that. So you just, yeah, we still have issues in St. Louis. Can we revisit my lesson on Kansas? Kansas City and Missouri? Yeah, because I was so shamed by it. I went into sort of a blackout and I don't really remember what I learned. Just real quick.
在这方面算不上最好。所以你只需……对，我们在圣路易斯仍然有问题。我们能重新温习一下我关于堪萨斯的课吗？堪萨斯城和密苏里州？对，因为我对此感到太羞耻了。我陷入了一种类似失忆的状态，我真的不记得我学到了什么。就简单快说一下。
You know, it should be fast. Kansas City is in Kansas or in Missouri? It's both. So it straddles the border between the two states. Kansas City is in Kansas or in Missouri? Both. So it straddles the border between the two states. Oh no, I thought there were two separate ones, no? You see? Wait, I think there's two separate, I don't even know. But they're kind of next to each other, they are.
你知道，得快点。堪萨斯城在堪萨斯州还是在密苏里州？两者都是。所以它横跨了两个州的边界。堪萨斯城在堪萨斯州还是在密苏里州？两者都是。所以它横跨了两个州的边界。哦不，我以为有两个不同的城市，不是吗？你看？等等，我觉得有两个不同的，我甚至都不知道。但它们紧挨着彼此，确实如此。
They are, they're really. Everybody sounds gray on this, just like me, so I'm not so dumb. It's confusing, I don't know if it's one that's separate, but I know, I think they're separate. They have to be separate because they are in different, you can't have a city cut in two. Today, Kansas City can.
它们确实是，真的。听起来每个人在这方面都很糊涂，就像我一样，所以我并不是那么笨。这太让人困惑了，我不知道这是一个还是分开的两个，但我知道，我觉得它们是分开的。它们一定是分开的，因为它们在不同的……你不能把一个城市切成两半。如今的堪萨斯城还真能。
Maybe you can. What about Minneapolis? Wait, what? It's not up there. It's not up there. Okay, so it says, I just Googled it. It says it remains two separately incorporated cities. They're right across from each other.
也许真的能。那明尼阿波利斯呢？等等，什么？不在这上面。不在这上面。好吧，上面写着，我刚刚谷歌了一下。上面说它仍然是两个独立注册的城市。它们就在彼此对面。
Wait, say it again, Sean. It says it's two separately incorporated cities, but together, along with a number of other cities and numbers, as part of the Kansas City Metropolitan Area. Separately incorporated? They're next to each other. Is there a picture of it, Sean? Does it straddle the border?
等等，再说一遍，肖恩。上面说这是两个独立注册的城市，但它们合在一起，还有许多其他城市和地区，构成了堪萨斯城大都会区的一部分。独立注册？它们紧挨着彼此。有它的照片吗，肖恩？它横跨边界吗？
Let me see. Yeah. And if so, like where? Partially there's a river in between them, and then partially it just goes right down state lines. One has the chiefs and one has meth. I don't know, I can't tell. One has meth, one has the Chiefs.
让我看看。是的。如果是的话，在哪儿？中间部分有一条河，然后部分地区就直接顺着州界延伸。一个有酋长队，一个有冰毒。我不知道，我分不清。一个有冰毒，一个有酋长队。
Well wait, who has the Royals? I think that's, I think, wait, Missouri claims that. They're both Missouri. Missouri has the Royals. Wait, no, it's Kansas, wait, no, no. Kansas, oh my God. It's Kansas City, Missouri is the one that's like everyone knows about.
等等，那谁拥有皇家队？我想那是……我想，等等，密苏里州声称拥有它。它们俩都在密苏里州。密苏里州拥有皇家队。等等，不对，是堪萨斯，等等，不对，不对。堪萨斯，哦天哪。堪萨斯城（密苏里州）是那个大家都知道的。
And Kansas City, Kansas is next to it. It's not fair. Right, so Kansas City, Missouri is the one that's like everyone knows about Kansas City Kansas is next to it Yeah, it's not fair right so Kansas City, Missouri is for the Chiefs Kansas City Kansas is probably for the Royals correct. I don't is that true Sean boy. It's on the border Can I tell you something right now? I never learned how to read a map No, they both play they also play in in Missouri just for what it's worth they they all are in, Missouri It's Missouri. Yes Other side st. Louis is on one side and Kansas City is on the other and I did get started in comedy in Kansas City So I know I should know I went to school in Kansas at Lauren University of Kansas. Oh, I don't know these things. Yeah
而堪萨斯城（堪萨斯州）就在它旁边。这不公平。对，所以堪萨斯城（密苏里州）是大家熟知的那个，堪萨斯城（堪萨斯州）在它旁边。是的，这不公平。对，所以堪萨斯城（密苏里州）有酋长队，堪萨斯城（堪萨斯州）大概有皇家队，对吧？我不……这是真的吗，肖恩小伙。它在边界上。我现在能告诉你一件事吗？我从来没学会怎么看地图。不，他们都在密苏里州比赛，不管怎样，他们都在密苏里州。是密苏里州。是的。另一边，圣路易斯在一边，堪萨斯城在另一边，我确实是在堪萨斯城开始我的喜剧生涯的，所以我知道我应该知道。我在堪萨斯的劳伦斯上过学，堪萨斯大学。哦，我不知道这些事情。是的。
Okay, okay. Yeah, it's not that's not Kansas University though home of of the Jayhawks. Wait, no it is. No, it's University of Kansas. But they say KU. It's, not a thing makes sense where I'm from. I don't really like, I gotta get out of there. I'm second guessing everything. Hey guys, can I just take a poll? You mean this podcast?
好吧，好吧。是的，那可不是堪萨斯大学，杰鹰队的故乡。等等，不对，就是。不，那是堪萨斯大学。但他们叫它KU。我老家没有一件事是合理的。我真的不喜欢……我得离开那儿。我开始对一切都产生怀疑了。嘿，伙计们，我能投个票吗？你是说这个播客？
Do we feel satiated on this? Do we feel good? Yeah, I feel good about it. JB, how are you? I'm still a little confused. I'm gonna do a separate Google later. Okay, go. Nicky, obviously we want to get to the roast
我们对此感到满足吗？我们感觉好吗？对，我感觉挺好的。JB，你怎么样？我还是有点糊涂。我待会儿要单独去谷歌一下。好吧，去吧。尼基，显然我们想聊聊吐槽大会，
because it's interesting. You've talked about it ad nauseam. You must be so fucking sick of it. Well, it's not gonna be boring to me because I haven't seen it yet. Oh, really? Okay, good. I saw it. You were like... You were incredible.
因为这很有趣。你已经喋喋不休地谈论过无数次了。你肯定烦透了吧。好吧，对我来说它不会无聊，因为我还没看过呢。哦，真的吗？好吧，很好。我看过了。你当时……你太不可思议了。
I mean, it was terrible. The very first time I met you was on the Rob Lowe. No, but I made a big impression. It was the Alec Baldwin one, clearly. Oh yeah, the Alec Baldwin one, yes. And you said one of the funniest jokes about me, and I still repeat it today to friends. What did I say? You said, you said, deliver, it was delivered perfectly, you said,
我是说，太糟糕了。我第一次见你是在罗伯·洛的那个上。不对，但我留下了深刻的印象。显然是亚历克·鲍德温的那场。哦对，亚历克·鲍德温的那场，是的。你讲了一个关于我的最好笑的笑话，直到今天我还在向朋友重复它。我说什么了？你当时说，你当时说——交付得太完美了——你说，
Shawn Hayes, oh my gosh, Will and Grace was the best you could do. I, uh... Oh my gosh, Will and Grace was the best you could do. I... I love this. I recycled that joke. You did? Yeah, because that's a good one that you can just use for anything.
肖恩·海耶斯，哦天哪，《威尔和格蕾丝》就是你能做到的最好极限了。我，呃……哦天哪，《威尔和格蕾丝》就是你能做到的最好极限了。我……我太喜欢这个了。我循环利用了这个笑话。真的吗？对，因为这是一个你可以用在任何地方的好笑话。
Like, yeah, I talk about, like, I've been about my boyfriend and, you know, we break up and date other people and then I look back at him and I just think, oh my God, like, after dating all these guys, I'm just like, he's the best, I can do. And that's it. So I've realized that I've recycled that one.
比如说，对，我谈论……比如我谈论我的男朋友，然后呢，我们分手了，跟其他人约会，然后我回过头看他，我就想，哦天哪，在跟所有这些家伙约会之后，我只是觉得，他就是我能找到的最好的了。就是这样。所以我意识到我把那个笑话循环利用了。
Yeah, that works. But I fanned out on you backstage, I just think you're hysterical. Oh, I'm such an, when you fanned out, that meant a lot to me. Well thanks. But it's true, these roasts, they've become a place to discover people, but I feel like you were already discovered, but for some reason, these roasts, they become a place
对，那挺管用的。但在后台我成了你的小粉丝，我只是觉得你太搞笑了。哦，我是个……当你表现得像个小粉丝时，这对我很重要。好吧，谢谢。但确实如此，这些吐槽大会已经成为了发掘人才的地方，但我觉得你其实早就被发掘了，可不知为什么，这些吐槽大会成了一个地方——
to discover people, but I feel like you were already discovered, but for some reason, this last one, everybody acts like they found you, but it's Nikki Glaser, she's been around forever, and she's been brilliant forever. So what did that feel like to be like, wait, I've been here, what are you guys all talking about? I didn't feel that way, I kind of was like,
去发掘人才，但我觉得你其实早就被发掘了，可不知为什么，最后这一次，每个人表现得好像他们刚刚发现了你一样，但她可是尼基·格拉泽，她已经出道好久了，而且一直都才华横溢。所以，当听到这种说法时，你心里是什么感觉：等等，我一直都在这儿，你们大家都在聊什么呢？我可不这么觉得，我当时有点像……
yeah, I've never been like, yeah, this, I've never been like, when is everyone gonna notice? And I just kind of, I really just take what comes to me and I never really wanna like fight for people to care about me. I want people to care about me on their own time. Yeah, yeah. So I've kind of been like, okay, when they do, they do.
是的，我从来没想过“大家什么时候才会注意到我呢”。我只是顺其自然地接受发生在我身上的事，我从来不想去争夺别人的关注，让别人在乎我。我希望人们按照他们自己的时间来关注我。对，对。所以我有点像是，好吧，他们什么时候注意到，那就是什么时候。
And felt pretty relaxed about it, but this was, I mean, it was insane. It was just like kind of an overnight thing that I never expected would happen in my career. I've always expected it just to be very slow and gradual. And I kind of liked the level of fame I had achieved. It's comfortable, I'm not that recognizable. My life isn't like disrupted by it ever, but there's some perks to it.
对此感觉挺轻松的，但这确实……我是说，这太疯狂了。这就像是一夜之间发生的事，我从没想过它会发生在我职业生涯中。我一直以为我的发展会非常缓慢、循序渐进。而且我其实挺喜欢我当时达到的名气水平的。那种感觉很舒服，我没那么容易被认出来。我的生活从不会因此被打扰，但它也有一些好处。
And I want for nothing. and I'm just good. It's like I can say no to things if I want, but now it's like, it was a huge bump overnight. And I'm sure you guys have experienced that in your careers as well. And it's just... I've had a lot of bumps. He's had a lot of bumps. Yeah.
而且我别无所求，我现在这样挺好的。就像我可以对不想做的事说不，但现在的情况是，它在一夜之间迎来了巨大的爆发。我确信你们的职业生涯中也经历过这种爆发。这只是……我经历过很多爆发。他经历过很多爆发。是的。
He took a lot of bumps. Sometimes I put them all together and make a nice fat fly. Sure. Sure. Oh, I remember the fly. Sure, sure. Oh, I remember the days. So, Nikki, do you find like now you're at the airport and people are like, roast me, burn me. Yeah.
他经历过很多爆发。有时候我把它们全捏在一起，做成一个又大又肥的苍蝇。当然。当然。哦，我记得那只苍蝇。当然，当然。哦，我记得那些日子。所以，尼基，你现在发现自己在机场时，人们会说：吐槽我吧，羞辱我吧。是的。
They don't say that, thank God, because it would be so mean coming out right away. And sometimes I will go there, but no, thank God they don't do that. They just say, did we go to camp together? You know that kind of thing. Like, where do I know you? Because I usually look like shit when I'm traveling. So I don't really look that recognized.
谢天谢地，他们不会这么说，因为一上来就这么说也太刻薄了。有时我也会主动提起，但谢天谢地，他们不会那样做。他们只会说：我们一起去过夏令营吗？你知道那种情况。就像：我在哪儿见过你？因为我旅行时通常看起来像个鬼一样。所以我其实看起来没那么容易被认出来。
I really do not look the same. I always steal that line that Dax said years ago, and I use it all the time. People go, when they have that moment of confusion, they go, I think I know you. And I go, yeah, I used to work at Subway around the corner Everyone's frequented a subway. Yeah, they're like and they're like maybe maybe a sandwich Old to be working in the don't you guys the reason I've never seen a roast I think is because I some I get yeah, I get so tight because I think that poor person is gonna have all these very good-natured jokes, right?
我真的看起来很不一样。我总是借用达克斯多年前说过的那句话，而且我经常用它。人们走过来，当他们陷入那种困惑的时刻，他们会说：“我觉得我认识你。”然后我说：“对，我以前在转角那家赛百味工作。”每个人都经常光顾赛百味。对，他们就会……他们会说，也许……也许是一个三明治。老是在……难道你们不觉得吗，我从来没看过吐槽大会的原因，我想是因为我有时……我变得非常紧张，因为我觉得那个可怜的人将要听到所有这些善意的笑话，对吧？
They're hard-hitting jokes, but the whole everybody knows the game here is that we're gonna like say nasty things about it. But like for the most part that person doesn't know these people. And so like where do these... I just don't know how that goes down okay for the subject. I think you have you can opt to not be a part of it. And when you opt to be a part of it... You can say no to it, sure. You know that... But can you say no to even to being there?
它们是辛辣的笑话，但大家都知道这里的游戏规则就是我们要说一些关于他的恶毒的话。但基本上那个人并不认识这些人。所以，这些……我只是不知道这对当事人来说怎么会是个好结果。我想你其实可以选择不参与其中。而当你选择参与其中时……你可以拒绝，当然。你知道那……但你连出席都能拒绝吗？
Like basically not be attending your funeral effectively. No, no, no, no. You have to be there. I think you have to be there. Yeah, that'd be weird if you're like, hey, let's just have a night where we shit on Knowing that he's at home going like what the fuck Although it'd be pretty funny. Yeah
基本上就是不参加你的葬礼，差不多是这样。不，不，不，不。你必须去。我想你必须去。是的，如果你说“嘿，让我们办个晚上来狠狠羞辱某人吧”，结果却发现他坐在家里一脸懵逼，那确实挺怪的。不过那也挺搞笑的。是的。
The person has to like pretend to laugh the whole time Yeah, and yeah kind of like okay like your feelings do get hurt like you can go in thinking Oh, they're only gonna go this far and then they go further I know I've seen it happen where they don't plan on you going there Like you can go in thinking, oh they're only gonna go this far, and then they go further. I know I've seen it happen where they don't plan on you going there. And they don't think, they just think. And that's really the only way to get to the huge laughs too is when it gets super uncomfortable, right?
当事人必须全程假装笑得很开心。是的，而且……有点像是，好吧……你的感情确实会受伤，因为你进去时以为，哦，他们最多也就开到这种程度，结果他们变本加厉。我懂，我见过这种情况，他们没打算让你说得那么过分。就像你进去时以为，哦，他们最多也就开到这种程度，结果他们变本加厉。我懂，我见过这种情况，他们没打算让你说得那么过分。而且他们根本不管，他们只管想说就说。而且这确实也是引爆全场大笑的唯一方法，那就是当现场变得超级尴尬的时候，对吧？
Of course. Yes. And to say that, like I went some places on the Tom Brady roast that I thought other people would go to and they didn't, and I was the only one that kind of said those names or brought up those subjects that were Kind of sore for him and you and it is crazy like I've seen old rose clips of like I don't like to watch myself
当然。是的。而且怎么说呢，我在汤姆·布雷迪的吐槽大会上抛出了一些我认为其他人也会涉及的话题，结果他们并没有，而我是唯一一个点出那些名字或提及那些对他和对你来说可能有点敏感的话题的人，这真的很疯狂。就像我看过以前的吐槽大会剪辑，我其实不喜欢看自己演出。
So when I would come up on my own feet, I'm like get out of here But when I was preparing for this roast I was like, okay try to channel what you've done in the past You've done you got to watch what people like about you I don't even you know, I just do it and then I don't watch it again So I'm just like watch it again and see what you bring you know, I just do it and then I don't watch it again. So I'm just like, watch it again and see what you bring to this. Because it had been four years since I'd done one. So I watched one and I was like,
所以每当我看到自己出场时，我都想说：滚开。但当我为这次吐槽大会做准备时，我就想：好吧，试着找回你过去的感觉。你得看看人们喜欢你什么。我甚至都不（你知道的），我只是演完了就不再回头看了。所以我当时就想：再看一遍，看看你能带来什么，你知道的，我只是演完了就不再回头看了。所以我当时就想：再看一遍，看看你能给这节目带来什么。因为距离我上次参加已经过去四年了。所以我看了一个片段，然后我就想：
who the fuck do you think you are saying this to people? You told Alec Baldwin all of this? Like what? Like I just didn't recognize this girl. And I'm like, she's got balls, but she's also like a psychopath. Like I just didn't, I really didn't, I couldn't believe that I did it,
你特么以为你是谁，竟然敢对别人说这种话？你把这些全告诉了亚历克·鲍德温？就像什么？就像我简直认不出视频里的这个女孩了。我就想：她真有种，但她也跟个精神病似的。就像我真的……我真的不敢相信那是我干的，
but I was like, I guess I have to channel that again. And you really just, they're set, Tom Brady's just set in your periphery a little bit back enough that you can't really see him when you're performing. So it helps. Does anybody know if any of these roasts have ever gone wrong where the subject just like says,
但我当时想：我想我必须再次找回那种状态。而且你真的……他们就坐在那儿，汤姆·布雷迪就在你的视野边缘，离得刚好够远，以至于你表演时其实看不到他。所以这很有帮助。有没有人知道，这些吐槽大会有没有哪一次搞砸过，就是当事人直接说：
whoa, whoa, whoa, fuck you and gets up and leaves. I read the Tom Brady thing, right, a little bit. I just kind of read little blurbs. Was he upset? Do you know? Yeah, I think he said that he, in hindsight, kind of regrets it. I don't really, he doesn't regret, he's glad he did it, but he didn't know that we would go some places.
“喂，喂，喂，去你妈的”，然后起身离开的？我读过关于汤姆·布雷迪那场的事，对吧，读了一点。我只是随便看了一些小片段。他生气了吗？你知道吗？是的，我想他说他在事后觉得有点后悔。我其实……他并不后悔，他很高兴自己参加了，但他没想到我们会去到那些地方。
I don't really know how he feels about it, but I totally see what he means, because I think you go into these things thinking that they're,. I don't really know how he feels about it, but I totally see what he means. Because I think you go into these things thinking that they're, you just don't know what people will dig up about you and see in you when they study you and look at your face that way. No one's ever gotten up and stopped it in the middle of it and just like left and just gotten pissed.
我其实不知道他是怎么想的，但我完全明白他的意思，因为我觉得你参加这些活动时以为它们是……我其实不知道他是怎么想的，但我完全明白他的意思。因为我觉得你参加这些活动时以为它们是……你只是不知道当别人研究你、用那种方式端详你的脸时，会把你过去什么黑历史给挖出来。从来没有人中途站起来叫停，然后直接离开并气急败坏吗？
I think there was one joke at a Comedy Central one where it was about, it was like a Paul Walker joke that Ludacris was there and he's friends with him obviously and he got up and like walked off stage I think there was but they cut it later. I think there was something like that that Yeah, you know one of my favorite was I don't know what happened to her. She was so funny Lisa lampanelli She was really really funny and then she quit. she quit. Yeah, did she really what happened? She does self. She does like self help talks now So she's like a motivational speaker now, but she got out of it because she was like it's too mean
我想在喜剧中心（Comedy Central）的某次节目中有一个笑话，是关于……那是个保罗·沃克的笑话，当时卢达克里斯也在场，他显然是保罗的朋友，然后他站起来气冲冲地走下了舞台。我想有过这种事，但他们后来剪掉了。我想确实有过类似的事情……是的。你知道我最喜欢的人之一是谁吗？我不知道她怎么了。她曾那么搞笑——丽莎·兰帕内利。她真的非常非常搞笑，然后她就不干了。她退出了。是的，她真的退出了吗，发生什么了？她现在做自我。她现在做自助指导讲座了。所以她现在就像是一个励志演说家，但她退出是因为她觉得这太刻薄了。
Yeah, it's tough. Yeah, right. She was one of the best she was one of the best She one of my favorite jokes that she said during the roast of William Shatner was she was going through his His credits, you know, and she goes remember TiVo when before you know, and she goes, remember TiVo, when before DVRs, there was TiVo. Yeah, we got it. And it made, if you liked something, it would suggest other things, you know? And so she goes up there and she goes,
是的，这很难。对，没错。她是最棒的之一，她是最棒的之一。她……我最喜欢的笑话之一是她在威廉·沙特纳的吐槽大会上说的，她当时在数他的……数他演过的作品，你知道的，然后她说：还记得TiVo吗，在你知道之前……然后她说：还记得TiVo吗，在DVR出现之前，还有过TiVo。对，我们懂。如果你喜欢某个东西，它会推荐其他类似的东西，你知道吗？所以她走上台去，然后她说：
yeah, William Shatner, I tried to TiVo TJ Hooker once, and TiVo suggested I punch myself in the cunt. See, that's great. That's a great joke. It's been off the air for a while. You can have some distance. Hey Sean, was Scotty just in a violent rage throughout the whole William Shatner roast?
是的，威廉·沙特纳，我曾经试图用TiVo录下《T.J. 库克》，结果TiVo建议我往自己逼上打一拳。看，这太棒了。这是一个绝妙的笑话。这节目已经停播一段时间了。你可以保持一些距离。嘿，肖恩，斯科特在整个威廉·沙特纳吐槽大会期间是不是都处于暴怒状态？
He didn't watch that, right? He watched it. Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, he enjoyed it. He wasn't happy about it. And Betty White, Betty White was on the panel and she got told like really crass jokes. It was so funny to see Betty White tell crass jokes. Yeah, I loved, one of my old, like from one of the early ones that was on Comedy Central years ago was
他没看那个，对吧？他看了。对，对，对。不，他挺喜欢的。他对此并不是很高兴。而且贝蒂·怀特，贝蒂·怀特也在嘉宾席上，然后有人对她开了非常低级粗俗的玩笑。看贝蒂·怀特讲低俗笑话真的太搞笑了。对，我喜欢……我以前最喜欢的笑话之一，来自多年前喜剧中心早期的某场节目，是
something about Andy Dick. I forget who said it, it might have been Jeff Ross. I wanted to fuck Andy Dick with Bea Arthur's dick. Is that what it was? Yes, yes, yes. have been Jeff Ross. I wouldn't fuck Andy Dick with Bea Arthur's dick. Is that what it was? Fucking great. And then they cut to Bea Arthur like, what? Yeah, the reaction shots are always the best.
关于安迪·迪克的。我忘了是谁说的，可能是杰夫·罗斯。我想用比阿特丽斯·阿瑟的鸡巴去操安迪·迪克。是那样吗？是的，是的，是的。可能是杰夫·罗斯。我才不会用比阿特丽斯·阿瑟的鸡巴去操安迪·迪克呢。是那样吗？太操蛋的棒了。然后镜头切到了比阿特丽斯·阿瑟，那一脸：哈？对，大家的即时反应镜头总是最好笑的。
That really sells it too, is that you gotta have the person that you're making fun of when they're cutting to them live, that really will make or break what people thought of your joke. If they're laughing along. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show.
这真的能起到烘托作用，就是你必须得让那个被你取笑的人在镜头直播切到他们时做出反应，这真的会成全或毁掉人们对你这个笑话的评价。如果他们也跟着笑的话。我们马上回来。好的，回到节目中。
So how did you first get, were they just like, hey, listen, who's a really, who's got a really shitty disposition? Nikki Glaser, let's get her in here. Yeah, she's a really, she's really mean to people. Yeah, it started early. Like, I remember I wrote, you know, jokes for people who were doing the roast early on, and then I did... Jeff Ross had a show called The Burn on Comedy Central, and I had a show on Comedy Central at the time,
所以你是怎么开始的？他们当时就像是：“嘿，听着，谁的脾气最烂？尼基·格拉泽，我们把她弄来。”是的，她对人真的很刻薄。是的，这很早就开始了。就像，我记得我早期为参加吐槽大会的人写过笑话，然后我做过……杰夫·罗斯在喜剧中心有一个叫《The Burn》的节目，当时我在喜剧中心也有一个节目，
so they threw me on that, and I had a really good showing on that. I just knew it was a place that I would really excel, and I needed to prove myself to Comedy Central for them to even consider me. So I would really excel and I needed to prove myself to Comedy Central for them to even consider me. So I worked really hard to do that TV show and I did a great showing and then,
所以他们把我塞进了那个节目，我在那上面表现得非常出色。我只是知道这是一个能让我真正大放异彩的领域，而且我需要向喜剧中心证明自己，好让他们考虑我。所以我需要真正大放异彩，我需要向喜剧中心证明自己，好让他们考虑我。所以我非常努力地去做了那个电视节目，而且我表现得很棒，然后，
and then people don't really wanna do Rose. So it's like, you know, they probably asked Whitney Cummings that year, they asked Amy Schumer and then they, Natasha Leggero and they probably didn't wanna do it and so they called up me and last minute, you know, you get booked like a week before, and you go, okay, and then you have a good one,
然后人们其实并不太想做吐槽大会。所以这就变成……你知道的，他们那一年可能问过惠特尼·卡明斯，他们问过艾米·舒默，然后他们又问了娜塔莎·莱格罗，而她们可能都不想做，所以他们就打电话找了我，而且是最后一分钟，你知道的，通常在演出前一周左右才敲定通告，然后你说“好吧”，接着你表现得很不错，
and then they ask you back the next time, and every time I kind of go, I don't know if I want to do this, because it's so much work, and I would really, I would always have like a mental breakdown right before it, and think, what am I doing? I'm going to bomb, and like cry, and have panic attacks about it.
然后他们下次还会邀请你，而每一次我都有点想说：“我不知道自己还想不想做这个，因为这工作量太大了。”而且我每次都会在演出前夕精神崩溃，心想：“我在干什么？我会砸场子的。”然后就会哭，并为此产生惊恐发作。
I don't know if you guys relate to that, where you say yes to things, and then you do them, and you go, don't, I don't know if you guys relate to that where you say yes to things. And then you do them and you go, don't, I'll never do this again. JB, tell her our rule that Matt Damon taught us. What? Which is, and you should apply this. Well, it was Ben who told Matt who told,
我不知道你们是否能感同身受，就是那种你对某些事情答应下来，然后你照做了，却心想……我不知道你们是否能感同身受，那种你对某些事情答应下来，然后你照做了，却心想：“再也不这样了。”JB，把马特·达蒙教给我们的规则告诉她。什么？也就是，你应该把这个用上。好吧，是本告诉马特的，然后马特告诉了……
but he said, if somebody asks you to do something, and you can start using this from this moment forward, Nikki, if somebody asks you to do something. Like two months down the line, you know, hey... He's like, six months, come and show up at this thing. Say to yourself, ask yourself, would I want to do it tomorrow? Oh, that's so good. If you don't want to do it tomorrow, say no.
但他说了，如果有人邀请你去做某件事，你可以从这一刻开始运用这一点，尼基，如果有人邀请你去做某件事。比如两个月后，你知道的，嘿……他就像是，六个月后，来这个活动露个面。问问你自己：我明天愿意做这件事吗？哦，这太妙了。如果你明天都不想做，那就拒绝。
It's unbelievably effective. You know what, I would even though, I would go, do you want to do it now? Sure, great. Because even tomorrow, sometimes I'm like, I'll be different tomorrow. But yeah, I'm always, I'll be different tomorrow. But yeah, I'm always, that's such a great,
这真的是难以置信地有效。你知道吗，即使这样，我还是会想：你现在就想让我做吗？当然，太棒了。因为即使到了明天，有时我也会想：我明天就会不一样了。但对，我总是……我明天就会不一样了。但对，我总是……这真的是一个绝妙的……
but this though, I need time to prepare, so I don't know how to answer that. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So what asked me, I always want to do it because I'm like the exposure, the potential of it, and then you get in it and it's like destroying my relationships, destroying my life, it's making me self-doubt all the time,
但话虽如此，我需要时间准备，所以我不知道该怎么回答。对，对，对。所以当别人问我时，我总是想答应，因为我想着曝光度、潜在的发展，然后当你真正卷入其中时，它就开始毁掉我的关系，毁掉我的生活，让我无时无刻不在自我怀疑，
and then it's over and I'm like, that was the greatest. I can't wait to do it again. And then everyone in my life goes, what do you mean you wanna do that again? But this time around, I actually implemented a system where I was happy the whole time and I know how to do it now and I can't wait to do it again. But the three before destroyed my life.
然后等这一切结束了，我就想：这简直太棒了。我迫不及待想再来一次。然后我生活中的每个人都说：“你疯了吗？你怎么还想再来一次？”但这一次，我实际上实行了一套系统，让我在整个过程中都保持快乐，我现在知道该怎么做了，我迫不及待想再来一次。但前三次简直毁了我的生活。
I totally relate to that. And obviously none of us, the three of us is a standup. But anytime I'm asked to kind, and obviously none of us, the three of us is a standup, but I, anytime I'm asked to kind of go and host something, you know, charity thing or whatever. That's not much work. A, it's a lot of work, but B, every single time I do it, I become a bigger and bigger grouch leading up to the day,
我完全能感同身受。显然我们当中没有人——我们三个都不是单口喜剧演员。但每当我被邀请去主持什么活动，慈善活动什么的。这工作量其实不大。A，这其实工作量很大；但B，每次我这么做，随着日子一天天临近，
leading up to the moment, and I'm fucking in the worst place. And then you do it, and everybody's, and it works, and you're like, that was fucking great, and everybody in your life is like, fuck man, you were a dick for the last two weeks. Yes, it's the dread. Every time. People have told me that no one hates
随着那一刻越来越近，我都变得越来越暴躁，我他妈的心情糟透了。然后你上了台，大家都在看，而且效果拔群，你会想：这他妈太棒了。结果你生活中的所有人都会说：靠，老兄，你过去两周简直是个混蛋。是的，这就是恐惧。每一次。有人曾对我说，没有人比你们更讨厌自己将要做的事情了。
what they are going to do more than you all the time. And then when I do it, even when I'm like about to go, when I'm on stage with a microphone, having the time of my life, unless I'm like, bomb, you know, like, so something's totally wrong. But as soon as I'm on stage with a microphone, having the time of my life, unless I'm like, something's totally wrong. But as soon as I'm performing, I'm in it, I'm doing great, but dread constantly up until that moment. And I think that's just, I don't know the way it goes.
然后当我做完之后，甚至当我正准备上台时——当我站在舞台上拿着麦克风、享受着人生中最美妙的时光时，除非我搞砸了，你知道的，那说明有什么地方彻底出问题了。但只要我一站在舞台上拿着麦克风、享受着人生中最美妙的时光时，除非我……那说明有什么地方彻底出问题了。但只要我一上台表演，我就完全投入其中，表现得很棒，只是在那之前内心里充满了恐惧。我想这就是……我不知道，事情就是这样。
Nikki, do you allow yourself to think, because you were saying earlier, you're really happy with where you find yourself. Like you've got an amount of relevance that you really enjoy, but also a nice amount of anonymity, where you can go to the grocery store, et cetera, et cetera. Do you allow yourself to think forward a year, five years, 10 years?
尼基，你允许自己去思考未来吗？因为你刚才说过，你对你现在的处境非常满意。你拥有你真正享受的知名度，但同时也保持着恰到好处的匿名性，你可以去杂货店，诸如此类。你允许自己去规划一年后、五年后、十年后的事情吗？
Do you allow yourself to think about goals and stuff like that? Where do you wanna go? No, and I wanna ask you guys about it too. Do you have goals or do you just keep saying yes to things as you go? And see where it takes you? Because I kind of just say yes to where it takes me.
你允许自己去想目标之类的事情吗？你想去哪里？不，我也想问问你们这个问题。你们有目标，还是只是在前进的过程中不断对事情说“好”？然后看它把你带到哪儿？因为我差不多就是顺其自然地接受生活带我去的地方。
And I think as a kid I had to. If you look at my credits, you see that I say yes to a lot of shit. We do a lot of switch backing, you know? We don't go right up the hill. This is for another podcast, but I'm a freak about goal setting and writing them down and
我想我小时候也是这样。如果你看看我的履历，你就会发现我对很多破事都说“好”。我们一直在走之字形路线，对吧？我们可不是径直冲上山顶的。这是另一个播客的话题，但我对设定目标并把它们写下来这件事简直是个狂热分子——
all that stuff. You are. For years and years and years. Are you teasing a new podcast right now, Sean? What's it called? That's exciting. Neto may be a part of it. Are we producing it with you?
所有那些东西。你确实是。多年来一直如此。肖恩，你现在是在预告一个新播客吗？叫什么名字？听起来真令人兴奋。内托可能会是其中的一部分。我们在跟你一起制作它吗？
No, no. Sean is a task master. Our joke is, Sean takes, if an email comes to the three of us about some sort of business thing, within 12 seconds before he thinks of his answer, he's responded. Yeah, I like to just check it off my list, though. I don't like to have anything in my inbox. I'm just...
不，不。肖恩是个严厉的主管。我们的笑话是，肖恩拿到……如果有一封关于某种商业事务的电子邮件发给我们三个人，在花12秒思考怎么回复之前，他已经回好信了。对，不过我喜欢把事情从我的待办清单上勾掉。我讨厌收件箱里有任何未处理的东西。我只是……
Me too. I have an absolutely clean inbox. Really? Yeah. And I'm like, I need 24 hours to think about it. I'm like, I'm not answering you. And then someone needs to text me, hey, you need to respond to that email.
我也是。我的收件箱绝对是空的。真的吗？对。而我却在想：我需要24小时来考虑一下。我心想：我才不回你呢。然后别人就得给我发短信：“嘿，你需要回复那封邮件。”
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's what I do. My email has just moved to texting. Nikki, so for the goal-less thing, the goal-less thing, since I'm like 22, 23 years old, I've been writing down goal-less, and they're stream of conscious goal-less. I'll write down on paper, I'll go one, two, three, and I'll just number it as they come in my head.
对，对，对，我就是那样。我的邮件功能都快退化成发短信了。尼基，所以关于无目标这事，无目标这事，自我大概22、23岁起，我一直在写目标清单，它们是意识流的目标清单。我会在纸上写下：一、二、三，随着它们出现在我脑海里，我只是给它们编上号。
There's the stupidest things like, I gotta lose five pounds, I gotta visit my mom more, I gotta make it, I gotta connect with this person about this project. You can cross that one off. Yeah, exactly, my mom passed away. So, but. Shit.
里面甚至有最蠢的事情，比如：我得减掉五磅，我得多去看看我妈，我得搞定这事、得因为这个项目跟这个人联系。你可以把那条划掉了。对，没错，我妈去世了。所以，但是。操。
My mom died like four or five years ago, it's hilarious. Anything in there about your dad's license plates? I didn't say it wasn't sad. Yeah, no, it was very sad, but you gotta laugh. I'm just saying that's the last thing that you have to do. Right, but anyway, so. I'm just saying that's the last thing that you have to do. Right. But anyway, so I would do all these things, and then at the bottom I put lifetime goals.
我妈在大约四五年前去世了，这太搞笑了吧。里面有没有关于你爸车牌号的内容？我没说这不令人难过。对，不，这非常难过，但你得笑。我只是说那是你最后一件要做的事。对，不管怎样，所以……我只是说那是最后一件要做的事。对。但不管怎样，所以我会把这些全做完，然后在底部写下终生目标。
This is like when I was 22, 23, I'm like, I want to host Saturday Night Live, I want to be a David Letterman, I want this, blah, blah, blah. And I went to therapy like years ago, and he goes, don't tell me a catastrophe happened. I go, what? He goes, they all came true. I go, every single thing on my list came true. And that's always... Yeah, so I got real depressed
这就像当我22、23岁时，我想：我想主持《周六夜现场》，我想成为大卫·莱特曼，我想要这个，巴拉巴拉巴拉。几年前我去看了心理医生，他问：“别告诉我发生了什么灾难。”我问：“什么？”他说：“它们全都成真了。”我说：“我清单上的每一件事都成真了。”那总是……是的，所以我变得非常沮丧，
because it was bad. Because then what's the point? What do you do next? Yeah, what's the point a little bit? So then you have- Do you make new ones? Yeah, so then, I mean- Buy a rope, buy a chair.
因为这太糟糕了。因为那样的话还有什么意义？接下来你该做什么？对，这样一来多少有点失去意义了吧？那你要定新目标吗？对，所以，我是说……买根绳子，买把椅子。
Find a beam, find a beam. Throw the rope over the beam. Kick the chair out. Regret it immediately. Try to get the rope off to no avail. Regret it immediately. And as I the rope off to no avail. As I'm doing it, I'm still checking it off. I'm not checking it right now. Try to yell to Scotty, but my windpipe is... With your toe on the desk. By the way, Sean, I noticed something about the way that you described. You sounded like you were from Brooklyn. You you go, since I'm 22. It's almost like that.
找根梁，找根梁。把绳子扔过梁。把椅子踢开。立刻后悔。试图把绳子解开却无济于事。立刻后悔。而在我……试图解开绳子却无济于事。当我这么做时，我还在继续打勾。我不是现在在打勾。试图对斯科特大喊，但我的气管被……用你的脚趾按着桌子。顺便说一句，肖恩，我注意到你描述方式的一个特点。你听起来像是从布鲁克林来的。你当时说：“自从我22岁起……”简直就像那样。
Since I'm 22 years old. And he said the most obvious thing in the world, but it isn't obvious until you hear somebody say it. He was like, well, you just gotta make new ones. And I was like, oh yeah, I guess I just gotta keep thinking. But then I've been trying to manifest stuff, and I'm doing these manifest meditations where it's like, just picture your life
自从我22岁起。而他说了一件世界上最显而易见的事，但在你听到别人说出来之前，它并不那么明显。他当时说：“好吧，你只要定新的就行了。”当时我就想：“哦，对，我想我只需要继续思考。”但后来我一直在尝试吸引力法则，我在做这种吸引力吸引冥想，就像是：想象一下你的生活，
with the thing you want. Feel that it's already happened and then you drift off to sleep and you try to get the feeling, not that you're doing the thing, but that you live in a world in which this is what you do, it's already happened. What is it, like Esther Hicks?
带着你想要的东西。去感受它已经发生了，然后你沉入梦乡，试着去体会那种感觉——不是你在做这件事的感觉，而是你生活在一个已经实现了这一点的世界里，它已经发生了。这是什么，就像埃丝特·希克斯（Esther Hicks）吗？
It's, what is his name? Neville Goddard, Neville Goddard. That's how everyone says his name on the YouTube. But yeah, please help. Yeah, no, here's a crazy story I have really fast if these guys will let me tell it. So it's when I... Are you going back to back? Yeah.
它是……那叫什么名字？内维尔·戈达德（Neville Goddard），内维尔·戈达德。YouTube上每个人都这么念他的名字。不过，是的，救命啊。对，不，如果这些家伙让我讲的话，我有一个非常疯狂的短故事。所以这是当我……你们俩这是要接龙吗？对。
Yeah. And then that's it. B2B? You went B2B already? Alright, man. B2B. I thought we left you on the beam. You don't know how to take a hint. Left you on the beam. You don't know how to take a hint. Left you on the beam. Still writing my goals down. Just the sound of a rope.
对。然后就结束了。B2B（背靠背接龙）？你已经B2B过了？好吧，老兄。B2B。我还以为我们把你留在房梁上了呢。你可真听不懂别人的暗示。把你留在房梁上了。你可真听不懂别人的暗示。把你留在房梁上。还在写我的目标。只听到一阵绳子的声音。
So anyway, when I was a kid, I was obsessed with the show Soap. Do you remember the show Soap? One of the great sitcoms. So in the opening credits, when they used to rehash the whole story of the show in the opening credits over and over every week, they would say, these are the Tates
所以不管怎样，当我还是个孩子的时候，我对电视剧《肥皂剧》（Soap）着迷得不行。你还记得《肥皂剧》这个节目吗？最伟大的情景喜剧之一。所以片头字幕里，每星期片头都在反复回放整个故事的背景时，他们会说：这些是泰特一家，
and these are the Campbells. And then, and blah, blah, blah, blah, and this is soap, right? And so these are the Tates, these are the Campbells. The Tates were the rich family, the Campbells were the poor family. Or the lower middle class, whatever. So the Tates, they would show this establishing shot
这些是坎贝尔一家。然后，巴拉巴拉巴拉，这就是肥皂剧，对吧？所以，这些是泰特一家，这些是坎贝尔一家。泰特家族是有钱人家，坎贝尔家族是穷人家。或者下中产阶级，随便吧。所以泰特家族，他们会展示这个建立镜头。
of this beautiful house, this brick house, and this gorgeous neighborhood. I was like, oh my god I grew up shit shit poor Nothing, you know, everybody knows my story. So then I was like I would race to the TV every every week to watch that opening I was obsessed with this house So about eight seven eight years later Scotty and I had a few to drink and we're going on a rabbit hole on YouTube of old openings of like 80s 90s sitcoms, you know, we saw Jason's we saw like like whatever. You know, like Facts of Life and whatever,
这座美丽的房子，这座砖房，还有这个华丽的社区。我当时就想，天哪，我小时候穷得要死，一无所有，你知道的，大家都知道我的故事。所以当时我每周都会飞奔到电视机前看那个开场，我简直对这座房子着迷了。所以大约七、八年后，我和斯科蒂喝了几杯，我们在YouTube上深入搜索了80年代、90年代情景喜剧的老开场，你知道的，我们看了杰森的，我们看了什么什么的。你知道的，比如《生活的事实》之类的，
The Hogan Family and like Dallas and like, you know, all of them. And I was like, oh, Scotty, we have to YouTube the opening credits of Soap. I was obsessed with this house as a kid. So we opened it and we're like, these are the Tates and these are the Campbells. And the house, right behind mine.
《霍根一家》，还有《达拉斯》，你知道的，所有的这些。然后我说，哦，斯科蒂，我们得在YouTube上搜一下《肥皂剧》的片头曲。我小时候就对这座房子着迷。于是我们打开视频，我们想，这些是特茨一家，这些是坎贝尔一家。而那座房子，就在我家后面。
Oh my God. Swear to God. This stuff is real. That you can. When I was a child. The manifesting things. Well, but so then if Nikki, if you're manifest, then you are allowing yourself to dream a little bit
哦，天哪。发誓。这是真的。你可以。当我还是个孩子的时候。心想事成这种事。好吧，不过既然这样，尼基，如果你在进行心想事成，那你就是在允许自己对未来做一点
of the future, yeah? And what does it look like? That's what I'm struggling with is like, I kinda like the way things are. And so I have an apartment, I don't own a home. And so I'm like, you know what, I should own a home. So let me just visualize the home I'm in. And then I think about like,
梦想，是吗？那它是什么样子的？这就是我所纠结的，我有点喜欢现状。所以我有一套公寓，我没有自己的房子。所以我心想，你知道吗，我应该有一栋房子。所以让我来想象一下我住的房子。然后我想到了，
we gotta get these cabinets redone. And then I'm like, oh, I gotta call someone. Like, I'm living in it. And then I go, I gotta call the landscaper. Like, there's so much work that starts happening. I go, I don't want this house. Like, let me take me back to my apartment. So I'm kind of like,
我们得把这些橱柜重新弄一下。然后我想，哦，我得给某人打电话。就像，我就住在里面。然后我想，我得找个园丁。天哪，有那么多的事情开始发生。我说，我不要这栋房子。把我带回我的公寓吧。所以我有点像，
I just really like the way things are now. So I feel, but I have goals of like, SN really like the way things are now so I feel but I have goals of like You know SNL I think is a good goal like hosting SNL. That's a great goal for Right, it's yes, I think it's happened There's I think it's not yet, but there's whisperings. There's whispering I think there's no way that it's not happening. Just knowing how that shit goes and what's out there, there's no way that they're not asking you this fall.
我真的很喜欢现在的生活方式。所以我觉得，但我的目标就像，SN真的非常喜欢现在的生活方式，所以我觉得，但我的目标就像，你知道SNL，我觉得这是一个很好的目标，比如主持SNL。那是一个很棒的目标，对吧，是的，我觉得这已经发生了，我想，虽然还没发生，但有风声了。有风声。我觉得这绝对会发生。只要了解那种事情的运作方式以及外界的情况，他们今年秋天绝对会邀请你的。
Thank you. Okay, so it's happened. That's the... That's already manifested. So I got, yeah, I don't know what's next, but what about Will and Jason, do you guys goal it up? I do. I mean, I sort of keep an eye on where I'd like
谢谢。好的，所以这已经发生了。这就是……这已经实现了。所以我有，是的，我不知道接下来是什么，但是威尔和杰森，你们俩有什么目标吗？我有。我是说，我大概会留意一下我可能想
to maybe be headed towards, but it's not that specific. I just want to be challenged with stuff that is right at the edge of what I'm able to handle. And I know that there's gonna be a day soon where I'm like, fuck this. Throttle back and just relax. And so I know that there's gonna be a day soon where I'm like, fuck this, throttle back and just relax. And so I know that's gonna come, so while I'm actually feeling this fuel, why not let it go?
要去的方向，但并没有那么具体。我只希望接受那些正好处于我能承受的极限边缘的事物的挑战。我知道很快就会有一天，我会想，去他的。把油门松开，好好放松一下。所以我知道很快就会有一天，我会想，去他的，把油门松开，好好放松一下。所以我知道那一天终会到来，既然我正感受着这股冲劲，为什么不顺其自然呢？
You know, let it, you know, drive towards it. Yeah, I do the same thing, Nikki, that you do, which is... And sometimes I do it super consciously and I actually set out to do it, but I do the same thing of sort of manifesting and I find that I do kind of manifest in real time most of the time. And it's been super, super, super effective for me. I don't know why.
你知道的，让它，你知道的，朝着那个方向前进。是的，我和你一样，尼基，我也会……有时我有意识地这么做，并且我确实打算这么做，但我也会做类似心想事成的事情，而且我发现我大多数时候都是在现实中实时进行心想事成。这对我来说超级、超级、超级有效。我不知道为什么。
Yeah. And I think I did it, that's why, when I was in high school, I used to just tell my friends, oh, I used to be obsessed with Dave Matthews and my friends all were too. And I would say, oh, I'll just like meet him someday and like get to, I'm gonna tell him like how I feel. And they were like, how would you meet him?
是的。我想我以前就是这么做的，这就是为什么，我在高中时，我经常告诉我的朋友们，哦，我以前迷恋戴夫·马修斯，我的朋友们也都一样。我会说，哦，我总有一天会遇到他，并且有机会，我要告诉他我的感受。他们就会问，你怎么能见到他？
And I'm like, well, I'm gonna be famous. And they were like, what? They just like, I remember their incredulousness of like that I thought that. And it was so obvious to me that that's what was gonna happen and that I'll be in his sphere. I had the same thing about Letterman. I used to watch Letterman at night when I was a kid,
我说，嗯，我会成名的。他们就说，什么？他们只是，我记得他们那种难以置信的表情，觉得我怎么会有这种想法。这对我来说太显而易见了，事情就是会这样发展，而且我会进入他的社交圈。我对莱特曼也有同样的看法。我小时候在夜里看莱特曼，
like in the 80s, like in high school, and I'd watch him at 12.30 and I'd think like, I bet you Letterman's gonna think I'm really funny. Yeah. And it worked out. And he does, yeah. And it worked out. Of course he does.
就像在80年代，在高中时，我在12点半看他的节目，心想，我敢打赌莱特曼会觉得我非常搞笑。是的。结果真的实现了。而且他确实觉得，是的。结果真的实现了。他当然觉得好笑。
And yeah, that kind of shit, I just, maybe that sort of dumb confidence of youth, I don't know. But... But Nikki, do you want to pursue... I know you've done tons of acting stuff, but is that important to you to pursue that lane as much as stand-up and everything else? Yes and no.
是的，那种鬼东西，我只是，也许那是年轻时那种愚蠢的自信吧，我不知道。但是……但是尼基，你想追求……我知道你演过很多戏，但对你来说，像追求单口喜剧和其他一切一样去追求那个方向，重要吗？算是由此及彼吧。
I mean, I think that's what I started pursuing initially in high school when I was like, how am I gonna get... How am I gonna meet Dave Matthews? I gotta get... Yeah. That was my real goal of being on TV, is that's the only way I could be in his sphere. And when I met him, I said the word sphere several times. I tried to be in your, it was really embarrassing. Well, where did that, were you living with,
我是说，我觉得这正是我在高中时最初追求的，当时我想，我要怎么才能……我要怎么才能见到戴夫·马修斯？我得去……是的。那是我上电视的真正目标，因为那是唯一能让我进入他的社交圈的方式。当我见到他时，我好几次说出了“社交圈”这个词。我试图进入你的，那真是太尴尬了。嗯，那是在哪里，你当时是和，
was your family super encouraging of your humor? And like, was mom and dad funny? Were your siblings like, where did the confidence come from that like, oh you know, if I think of something funny, I should share it because that usually works out. That did not come until way later. So I was like, okay, I'll be an actress.
你的家人非常支持你的幽默感吗？还有，你爸爸妈妈搞笑吗？你的兄弟姐妹们呢？这种自信是从哪里来的，觉得“哦，你知道的，如果我想到了什么搞笑的事，我就应该分享出来，因为通常都会成功”。这种自信直到很久以后才出现。所以当时我想，好吧，我要当个演员。
And I was not getting the parts in school plays. And I didn't even go to like a theater school. So it was like, you know, I was getting Town's Person B and stuff so I was getting feedback like this isn't for you like to act and so I was first not even Townsperson A always B and and I would think I would get the lead and then I'd be at the bottom of the list and I would cry and then I go oh I guess I'll go do field hockey and it was terrible at sports so I was like didn't really but I
而且我在学校的话剧里根本选不上角色。我甚至没去读什么戏剧学校。所以就像，你知道的，我只能演镇民B之类的角色，所以我得到的反馈是这不适合你，你不适合演戏，所以我一开始甚至连镇民A都演不上，总是演B，而且我本来以为自己能演主角，结果却排在名单的最底部，然后我就会哭，接着我想，好吧，我去打曲棍球吧，我对运动一窍不通，所以我当时就觉得，其实也没有，但我
was so depressed that it wasn't gonna work out. I auditioned for theater school, didn't get in anywhere, and I was really like, I guess I'll just like, have to kill myself. Like, I really was thinking that, because what's the point of living if you're not gonna be on TV and performing in some way? But I had no way to do it.
因为事情没有按照预期发展而感到非常沮丧。我去面试了戏剧学校，结果到处都没被录取，我真的觉得，好吧，我大概只能自杀了吧。我当时真的是这么想的，因为如果你不能上电视，不能以某种方式进行表演，活着还有什么意义？但我又不知道该怎么做。
I just thought acting's the only way. I had no idea there were other things. I didn't even look into it. I know I couldn't sing or dance. I had no idea there were other things. I didn't even look into it. I know I couldn't sing or dance. I didn't kind of sing. What did your parents do? My dad's in the cable business and my mom was just a homemaker.
我只觉得演戏是唯一的出路。我根本不知道还有其他事情可做。我甚至都没有去了解过。我知道我不会唱歌也不会跳舞。我根本不知道还有其他事情可做。我甚至都没有去了解过。我知道我不会唱歌也不会跳舞。我也不会怎么唱歌。你父母是做什么的？我爸爸做有线电视行业的，我妈妈是个家庭主妇。
And so they were just, they were always supportive and I come from a really funny family and they have great taste in comedy. So I was always consumed. My dad introduced me to Conan when I was in eighth grade and was like, you gotta check out this show. And then that changed my life and Seinfeld I was obsessed with and friends.
所以他们只是，他们一直都很支持我，而且我来自一个非常搞笑的家庭，他们对喜剧有着极高的品位。所以我一直沉浸其中。我上八年级时，我爸爸把我引向了柯南，对我说，你得看看这个节目。然后那改变了我的人生，还有《宋飞正传》，我曾经超级迷恋它，还有《老友记》。
I was really, I loved comedy, but I wasn't, stand-up didn't do much for me. I just wasn't even paying attention to it. And then I went to college and I was like, long story short, I had a terrible eating disorder because I was pretty much like, I just want to die. My life sucks and nothing's going the way I want it to. And I have because I was pretty much like, I just want to die. My life sucks and nothing's going the way I want it to
我是真的很喜欢喜剧，但我当时并不，单口喜剧对并没有给我带来多大触动。我甚至根本没去关注它。后来我上大学了，简单来说，我患上了严重的进食障碍，因为我差不多是那种心态，我只想死。我的生活糟透了，一切都不顺心。我有，因为我差不多是那种心态，我只想死。我的生活糟透了，一切都不顺心，
and I have to go to college and figure out what I want to do for a living, but I don't want to do anything except perform and I'm not good at that and everyone tells me I'm not good at it. Like, I was taking voice lessons to be a singer and my voice teacher like took my mom aside and said this is a waste of your money.
我必须去上大学，弄清楚自己以后想靠什么谋生，但我什么都不想做，只想表演，而我又做不好，每个人都告诉我我做不好。比如，我当时在上声乐课想当个歌手，我的声乐老师甚至把我妈妈拉到一旁说，这简直是在浪费你的钱。
She doesn't have it. Like, I was getting, I was getting, the voices were sent to my mom. And so I just was so discouraged, and then I just got an eating disorder that I was like, oh, I'll just die of this. And I really wanted to, I was really, like slowly just dying, and then I was hospitalized, it was right after high school,
她没有这方面的天赋。就像，我一直在承受，这些负面评价都传到了我妈妈耳朵里。所以我当时非常沮丧，然后我就得了进食障碍，我心想，哦，我干脆因为这个死掉算了。我是真的很想，我真的就是，在慢慢地死去，后来我住院了，那是在高中刚毕业后，
and I was going off to college, I was hospitalized over the summer, and then I needed to get out of there, and so I lied, and I was like, I just gotta go away to college, and was hospitalized over the summer, and then I needed to get out of there, and so I lied, and I was like, I just gotta go away to college, and then I can like kind of die off alone without people monitoring what I'm eating.
我要去上大学了，整个夏天我都在医院里，然后我需要离开那个地方，所以我撒了谎，我说，我必须去外地读大学，整个夏天我都在医院里，然后我需要离开那个地方，所以我撒了谎，我说，我必须去外地读大学，然后我就可以一个人慢慢地死掉，不用别人监视我吃东西了。
Oh my God, Nikki, this is awful. It's so sad, it's so sad. But I really was like, what's the point? I just didn't know what the point of life would be if I wasn't a performer, because I also, I wanted, I feel like my parents really pay attention to TV in a way that I always wanted to be paid attention to, and I think that's why I wanted to get on TV,
哦天哪，尼基，这太可怕了。太令人难过了，太令人难过了。但我当时真的觉得，有什么意义呢？我只是不知道如果我不是一个表演者，生命的意义何在，因为我也，我希望，我觉得我的父母对电视的关注方式正是我一直渴望得到的关注，我想这就是为什么我想上电视的原因，
was that even though they love me so unconditionally, I just didn't feel it. I was just a very sensitive child. Anyway, they're great parents. How did you overcome that moment? How did they prove that they loved you? Sorry, go ahead. Well, they proved they loved, they're still working on it,
就是尽管他们无条件地爱我，但我就是感受不到。我只是一个非常敏感的孩子。不管怎样，他们是伟大的父母。你是怎么克服那个时刻的？他们是怎么证明他们爱你的？抱歉，你继续。嗯，他们证明了他们爱，他们还在努力，
but I have theories that they do. But the love seems to amp up a little bit when I bring them to the Tom Brady roast. And that's the thing. You know, like, there's a little bit more of text messages from my mom of, I've always loved you, like final, okay. But wait, that's really,
但我有理论证明他们确实爱。不过当我带他们去参加汤姆·布雷迪的吐槽大会时，这份爱似乎稍微增强了一点。事情就是这样。你知道的，就像，我妈妈发给我的短信稍微多了一点，上面写着“我一直都爱着你”，就像是最终定论一样，好吧。等等，这真的是，
what an interesting meaning to tell me till now. More than your father does. Yeah. And we will be right back. And now, back to the show. Nikki, what an interesting story. How did you overcome that enormous hunt from high school to college?
直到现在才告诉我，这真是个有趣的含义。比你父亲表达的还要多。好的，我们马上回来。现在，欢迎回到节目中。尼基，这是一个多么有趣的故事啊。你是如何克服从高中到大学那段巨大的低谷的？
You just touch bottom and then just- Well, I was like ready to fucking go. Every night I would be like, please die in your sleep because I was just hungry all the time and it's like you know what? It's like to be hungry Jason and so And so it's uh Yeah, I was I was waiting for that to like just end it because I was cold all the time, I was hungry, I looked insane so I couldn't really make friends because everyone's just like, this girl is like a skeleton
你就是跌入谷底，然后就——嗯，我当时已经准备好他妈的去死了。每天晚上我都在想，求求你在睡梦中死去吧，因为我总是很饿，那种感觉你知道吗？杰森，那种饥饿感是什么滋味，所以……所以呃，是的，我当时在等待那种状态来结束一切，因为我总是很冷，我很饿，我看起来像个疯子，所以我根本交不到朋友，因为每个人都觉得，这个女孩就像个骷髅
who looks so weird and looks so brittle and I was about to die and my hair's falling out and I'm at my freshman year of college, I don't have any friends and I need to make some. So I think I just turned up my personality a lot just because I looked so crazy, that I needed, the only way to make friends was to be larger than life.
看起来太诡异了，看起来那么脆弱，我当时都快死了，头发大把大把地掉，我正读大一，我没有任何朋友，我必须得交几个。所以我想我当时只是极大地放大了我的个性，因为我看起来太疯狂了，我需要，交朋友的唯一方法就是表现得超乎寻常。
And so I started being funnier. I just like, it just was an adaptive trick. You made yourself funny. I did, because no one would like me otherwise. And then all of my friends, I got friends because it was funny and really outgoing, and all my friends would say, God, when we first saw you, we were like,
所以我开始变得更幽默。我只是，这只是一种适应性的把戏。你让自己变得幽默了。我确实这么做了，因为否则没有人会喜欢我。然后我所有的朋友，我交到朋友就是因为我很幽默而且非常外向，我所有的朋友都会说，天哪，我们第一次见到你的时候，我们都在想，
who is that girl? And then we kind of forgot that you looked like that because people would go to my friends and be like, we're really worried about her. And they'd be like, we don't even know what you're talking about. Because I did really just overcompensate for how sick I was with my personality.
那个女孩是谁？然后我们有点忘记了你以前长那样，因为人们会去找我的朋友说，我们真的很担心她。而他们会说，我们根本不知道你在说什么。因为我确实用我的性格过度弥补了我生病的状态。
And that's when people started going, you should be a standup comedian. And once I heard that, I go, okay, what's that? Okay, I mean, I knew what it was, but then I Googled it and I saw Sarah Silverman and then that changed my world. And that was like, okay, I'll just do that. I was gonna say, what was the thing that inspired you to,
然后就在那时，人们开始说，你应该去当单口喜剧演员。一听到这话，我就想，好吧，那是什么？好吧，我的意思是，我知道那是什么，但我随后在谷歌上搜索了一下，看到了萨拉·西尔弗曼，这彻底改变了我的世界。当时我就觉得，好吧，我就去干那个。本想问你，是什么启发了你...
as you said, turn it up? What was the thing where, I know you were, your hair was falling out, was you kind of rock bottom, but what made you? I didn't want to be made fun of. I wanted to be the first to make the joke about how thin I was. Or what... I wanted to be so extraordinary in my personality that no one would notice how scary I looked or how concerning...
就像你说的，把它调大？当时是怎么回事，我知道你当时头发掉得很厉害，那算是你的低谷吗，是什么让你？我不想被取笑。我想第一个拿自己有多瘦开玩笑。或者说……我想让自己的性格变得如此出众，以至于没有人会注意到我看起来有多可怕，或者有多令人担忧……
And so, I think that was it. You know, like the fat kid in school can be the class clown or most... I had never experienced that before, where my looks, like, made people talk about me and whisper about me and make fun of me. I always just in high school wanted to just disappear. I didn't want boys to make fun of me. I just was so scared of any attention. I wanted attention on stage when I told you you could.
所以，我想就是那样吧。你知道的，就像学校里的胖孩子可以成为班里的滑稽人物或者最……我以前从未经历过那种情况，我的外表会引起别人的议论、窃窃私语和嘲笑。在高中时，我总是只想消失。我不想让男生嘲笑我。我对任何关注都感到非常害怕。我只有在舞台上时才希望得到关注，就像我之前跟你说过的那样。
But I really was like... People from high school are just like, you are a comedian? Like, I just kind of was... I didn't really... I didn't make big waves in high school. But... And then when I turned it up, that's when people started telling me that. And then as soon as I looked into it, I was like, oh, of course this is it. I've always, I'm like writing comedy. I have, I love comedy and then acting.
但我真的觉得……高中同学的反应就像是，你居然是个喜剧演员？就好像我以前……我其实没怎么在高中里引起轰动。但是……后来当我真正全力以赴时，大家才开始这么对我说。而且我一深入了解，就觉得，哦，当然就是这个。我一直以来都在写喜剧，我热爱喜剧，然后是表演。
The thing I found hard was like being someone else. I really think it was just, I was always trying to run away from who I was. And I finally found something that celebrated. I could say the weirdest things and the darkest things that I was ashamed of into a microphone and then people liked me more because of the things that I hate the most about myself. So that was really cool. Honesty, which is the reason that mental illness exists is because people aren't being honest.
我觉得最难的事情是假装成别人。我真的觉得当时我总是在逃避真正的自己。然后我终于找到了一个能让我展现自我的东西。我可以把那些最古怪的、最让我感到羞耻的黑暗面对着麦克风说出来，结果人们反而因为我最讨厌自己的那些地方而更加喜欢我。所以这真的很酷。诚实，精神疾病之所以存在，就是因为人们不够诚实。
And so that really helped me heal. But the one thing that you did not generate overnight was, I mean, you're obviously really smart. And so that is something that you probably sort of saved you in the end from a lot of stuff was that you're not a dummy. You're really bright. By the way, you lost Sean when you said hungry all the time. Sean looks so confused.
这确实帮助我恢复了过来。但有一点并不是你一朝一夕就能培养出来的，我是说，你显然非常聪明。所以这可能在最后帮你在很大程度上避开了许多麻烦，因为你并不笨。你真的很聪明。顺便说一句，当你提到一直觉得饿的时候，肖恩已经跟不上你的思路了。肖恩看起来困惑极了。
What do you mean? What do you mean? I'm never hungry. I'm never hungry. So then you found then that the thing that was bumming you out internally was actually material. And that that is like, it actually becomes an asset to you. And that vulnerability is one of the huge keys to comedy.
你什么意思？什么意思？我从来不饿。我从来不饿。所以你后来发现，那个让你内心沮ศ丧的东西其实是物质的，而这就像是，它实际上成了你的资产。这种脆弱性是喜剧的重大关键之一。
You know, you gotta pull your pants down a little bit. There's nothing funny about no problems. Just say the honest thing. And people can't even believe you're saying it because most people aren't honest at that level. And so whenever I'm on stage and I'm trying a new bit and it's not going well, and I've kind of lost the audience and they know that I know, I just like,
你知道的，你得把裤子往下脱一点。没有任何问题是可笑的。只要说实话就行了。人们甚至不敢相信你在说真话，因为大多数人达不到那种诚实的高度。所以每当我在台上尝试新的段子却进展不顺利时，我有点失去了观众，而他们也知道我知道这一点，我就会像……
my trick for that is just to stop and just say the honest thing. Yeah, because then it's so healing and you can't lose. And you just go, that bombed, and you guys don't like me anymore, right? And then they laugh so be revealed be revealing too in that way and be vulnerable and JB And I've often said there's nothing funny about a six-pack in that right like no you know what I mean like this It's just not fucking funny exactly because a fuck look how quick will ferrell takes his shirt off It's fucking works every time. It's so good.
我应对这个的小技巧就是停下来，直接说实话。是的，因为那样真的很治愈，而且你不会输。然后你直接说，刚才演砸了，你们都不喜欢我了吧？然后他们就笑了，所以在那种情况下也要坦诚、做自己，表现出脆弱的一面。JB和我经常说，六块腹肌一点也不好笑，对吧？就像，你懂我的意思吗？这他妈的一点也不好笑。没错，因为他妈的你看威尔·法瑞尔脱上衣有多快。每次都管用。太棒了。
I fucking love him for it. But that's the struggle though, because I also wanna be hot. Like listen, we're all funny, but we all care about looking aesthetically. Look at this Henley. Did you get a good look at the Henley shirt? I've heard about this Henley.
我他妈太爱他这一点了。但这也是个挣扎，因为我也想变得性感。听着，我们都很搞笑，但我们也都关心外在美。看看这件亨利衫。你好好看看这件亨利衫了吗？我听说过这件亨利衫。
Look at that drape. Did Amanda buy that for you? She did. It's good. But yeah, we all care about what people think about how we look, and then people go, but you're funny, you don't need to care. And it's like, well, it is a part of it,
看看那块布料。那是阿曼达给你买的吗？是的。挺好的。不过是的，我们都在意别人对我们外表的看法，然后有人会说，但你很搞笑，你不需要在意。而这就像是，嗯，这也是其中一部分，
and honestly, I'm being honest when I say I'm insecure about my looks, so that's still part of it for me. I can't help that I do care about my looks, even though you don't need to, you're not a model. First of all, everybody does, and everybody does, no matter what job, and Sean's right, yours should be cute,
说实话，当我说我对自己的长相感到不自信时我是认真的，所以这对我来说仍然是其中的一部分。我没办法不在乎自己的长相，尽管你不需要在乎，你又不是模特。首先，每个人都在乎，不管做什么工作都一样，肖恩说得对，你的外表应该清爽可爱，
but think about it this way. Because of the very nature of what you do, people comment, and we live in a world now where we see those comments, and we hear that stuff so much more readily. So of course, it makes sense that you'd be, when people say that, I remember years ago, some friends from Toronto had grew up with like, oh fuck, Willie, all you actors,
但换个角度想想。由于你所从事职业的特殊性，人们会发表评论，而我们现在生活在一个能更轻易地看到这些评论、听到这些声音的世界里。所以理所当然地，当人们那样说时，你会……我记得多年前，几个和我一起长大的多伦多朋友曾说过，去他的，威利，你们这些演员，
hey, you guys just care about how you look. I'm like, yeah, because everybody's talking about it when you do something, they go, fuck, you look like shit. By the way, I got an on-camera job. Yeah, I got an on-camera job. Okay. And people go like, fuck, man, that guy, Arnett looked like shit in that thing.
嘿，你们只关心自己的外表。我想说，是的，因为每个人都在谈论它，当你做了什么时，他们就会说，操，你看起来真像一团屎。顺便说一句，我得到了一份出镜的工作。是的，我得到了一份出镜的工作。好的。然后人们就会说，操，伙计，阿奈特在那东西里看起来真像一团屎。
You're like, oh, thanks a lot, man. Yeah. They will say, and the comments, it's insane that there are comments under every single clip or video or picture that is of you. David Spade told me a while ago, he was like, you know back when I did the Hollywood Minute
你就会觉得，哦，太谢谢你了，兄弟。是的。他们会说，评论区里，每一段剪辑、每一个视频或每一张关于你的照片下面都有评论，这真是太疯狂了。大卫·斯佩德不久前告诉我，他说，你知道吗，当年我做《好莱坞一分钟》的时候
during Weekend Update, that was the only time celebrities got mocked mercilessly for a minute. That was the only time celebrities got like mocked mercilessly for like a minute. That was the only time that celebrities were being made fun of ever because it was just all... Stern used to do it a bit right before that. Right, okay, so there's like two outlets for it. And now it's all people do.
在《周末更新》节目中，那是唯一名人会受到无情嘲讽一会儿的时候。那是唯一名人会受到大约一分钟无情嘲讽的时候。那是唯一一次名人受到取笑的时候，因为这全都是……斯特恩在那之前不久也经常这么做。对，好吧，所以大约有两个这样的渠道。而现在，这就是所有人都在做的事。
I will say, I like the way that you've offset it. And I was gonna bring this up before when you talked about that you moved back to St. Louis. We had somebody on recently who moved back to the Midwest and it's made me long for, I don't know why recently, I really long for not living on either coast. I've had this sort of dream. It makes me feel kinda good because there is something.
我想说，我很喜欢你错开它的方式。我之前就想提这个，当你谈到你搬回圣路易斯的时候。我们最近请过一位搬回中西部的嘉宾，这让我渴望——我不知道为什么最近——我真的很渴望不住在任何一个海岸。我有过这样一种梦想。这让我感觉挺好的，因为某种东西确实存在。
Small town. Yeah, a little bit. There's something kind of. Yeah, but what's that quote? Doesn't matter where you go, there you are. You know? Like, you're gonna feel the same no matter where you go. I agree. Yeah, I'm not looking at it as a remedy for how I'm necessarily feeling.
小镇。是的，有一点。有点那种感觉。是的，但那句名言怎么说来着？无论你走到哪里，你都在那里。你知道吗？就像，无论你走到哪里，你的感觉都是一样的。我同意。是的，我并不把它当作我当前感受的解药。
I'm just talking about my day-to-day experience. Like, what do I want that experience to be? Your environment, yeah. Yeah, you just want to get carjacked a little. Yeah, in the Midwest. Desperate to be. I get what you mean. I'm a workaholic and I lock up my liquor on the coast and I go and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can
我只是在谈论我的日常体验。比如说，我希望那种体验是什么样的？你的环境，对。对，你只是想稍微被劫车一下。对，在中西部。渴望被劫。我明白你的意思。我是个工作狂，我在海岸把我的酒锁起来，然后我去，我就可以去拿，我就可以去拿，我就可以去拿，我就可以去拿，我就可以去拿，我就可以
go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I can go get it and I coast and I go and I can go get it if I can get A key and like deliberately go get it, but it's not just waiting for me in my room in st Louis I kind of I'm away from work and can and don't have to drive myself crazy with it And I can forget that that's that all that stuff matters When you really are in New York and LA, you get sucked into the machine of like,
去拿到它，我可以去拿到它，我可以去拿到它，我可以去拿到它，我可以去拿到它，我可以去拿到它，我可以去拿到它，我可以去拿到它，我可以去拿到它，我可以去拿到它，我可以去拿到它，我顺其自然地生活，我可以去拿，只要我能拿到一把钥匙，并且刻意去拿它，但它并不是就在圣路易斯的房间里等我，我算是离开工作了，可以不必为此发疯，我也能忘掉所有这些事情有多重要。当你真正身处纽约和洛杉矶时，你就会被卷入那种机器般的运转中，比如
you've gotta do more, it's not enough. And comparing yourself more, even though they're all waiting for you on Instagram to compare yourself to, I feel it more here. Which is good sometimes. When I was doing the roast, I was like, I'll go to LA for a month and a half before that to get in the zone of like, competitiveness
你必须付出更多，这还远远不够。而且你会更多地与人比较，尽管他们在Instagram上都在等着你去和他们比较，但在这里我更能感受到这种竞争。有时这其实是件好事。当我做吐槽节目的时候，我想，在此之前我要去洛杉矶呆一个半月，好进入那种充满竞争的状态。
and running my set every night and like feeling like I'm not enough and needing to prove myself. But I couldn't do that in St. Louis. I couldn't just fly and do the roast. I would've come with this Midwest ease. I needed to come in strong and insecure. What's your day-to-day like in St. Louis then,
每晚登台表演，觉得自己还不够好，需要证明自己。但在圣路易斯我做不到这一点。我不能直接飞过去参加吐槽大会。我本来会带着那股中西部的随性而来。我需要带着强大却又缺乏安全感的状态来。那么你在圣路易斯的日常生活是怎样的，
if you're not working? Wake up, go into my podcast room, which is next to my bedroom, do a podcast, then I go to a Pilates class, then I go to Starbucks and pretend to write, and then I, you know, that whole thing, where you open up your laptop and then you just, yeah. That's a whole thing that I love.
如果你不工作呢？醒来，去我的播客室（就在我卧室旁边），录一期播客，然后我去上普拉提课，再去星巴克假装写作，接着我，你知道的，就是那一整套流程，打开笔记本电脑然后就，对。这就是我非常喜欢的一整套流程。
Are you working? You guys are too famous to do that now. That's the fame I don't want to be, is like where I can't go to Starbucks still and just sit in a coffee shop. Careful, here it comes. It's coming. I gotta really enjoy it while I got it, but yeah, I just sit there in a coffee shop. Careful, here it comes. It's coming. I gotta really enjoy it while I got it.
你在工作吗？你们现在太有名了，不需要那样做了。那是我不想要的名气，就像我不能再去星巴克坐在咖啡馆里一样。小心，它来了。它要来了。我得趁现在好好享受它，不过是的，我就坐在咖啡馆里。小心，它来了。它要来啦。我得趁我拥有的时候好好享受它。
But yeah, I just sit there in an online shop and then I go back home and play my guitar a little bit and then I go to a voice lesson. I'm still trying to be a singer, so I just, yeah, and then I go hang out with my parents, hang out with my niece and nephews and then, you know. And that acting desire you said, or just sort of atrophied way back when
不过是的，我只是坐在那儿浏览网店，然后回家弹一会儿吉他，再去上声乐课。我还在努力成为一名歌手，所以我就，是的，然后我和父母待在一起，和我的侄子侄女们待在一起，然后，你知道的。至于你说的那个表演的愿望，还是很久以前就有些萎缩了呢？
and there's no desire there at all? No, there totally is. I think that it would be so fun to do it. But it's, being on set is really exhausting and boring sometimes. Yeah, being on set can be very boring, exactly. But, but what- And on the road is easy for me. I don't even have to think about it.
而且完全没有那种渴望吗？不，完全有的。我觉得做那件事会很有趣。但是，在片场有时真的很累人又无聊。对，在片场确实很无聊，没错。但是，但是什么——而巡演对我很轻松。我甚至都不用去想它。
I just walk on stage. But also just the creative difference of, an actor has to fit lines that were written before they come in. So your job is to fit a pre-existing character in line. As a stand-up, it's the total opposite. You're already there and then you're writing lines to fit you. That's what I like about it.
我只是走上舞台。但这也是一种创造上的差异，演员必须去契合在他加入之前就写好的台词。所以你的工作是去契合一个既有的角色和台词。而作为一名单口喜剧演员，情况完全相反。你已经站在那儿了，然后你写出适合你自己的台词。这就是我喜欢它的地方。
Yeah, okay. But what about the, I always wait till the last second for everything. So that doesn't work in acting. You can't be just like, you know, binging your lines right before and memorizing it. I'm sure sometimes that is the way it has to happen, but there's a lot of preparation and forethought
是的，好吧。但是那件事呢，我做事总是拖到最后关头。所以这在表演中行不通。你不能只是在临演前才临时抱佛脚去背台词。我确信有时情况确实如此，但其中需要做大量的准备和深思熟虑
that goes into being an actor and preparing. And I feel like as a stand-up comedian, as long as I'm just showing up as myself, I can get the job done. Like I don't like a lot of review. I don't like a lot of rehearsal. I don't like to critique myself because then I start to see the flaws. So with stand-up Like I don't like a lot of review. I don't like a lot of rehearsal. I don't like to critique myself because then I start to see the flaws.
演员在准备过程中付出了很多努力。我觉得作为一个单口喜剧演员，只要我以真实的自我出场，就能完成工作。比如我不喜欢太多的回顾，不喜欢太多的排练，不喜欢批判自己，因为那样我会开始看到缺点。所以对于单口喜剧来说，我不喜欢太多的回顾，不喜欢太多的排练，不喜欢批判自己，因为那样我会开始看到缺点。
So with stand up I'm just like, I can just be in a conversation and I'm just with someone and be like talking about something really sad and crying and then walk on stage and do it and then walk off and get right back to it. I don't have to like get in a zone. It just seems like a lot of work.
所以对于单口喜剧，我就是觉得，我可以在一段对话中，和某人在一起，聊着一些非常伤心的事然后哭泣，接着走上台去表演，下来之后又能马上回到那个状态。我不需要特意去进入某种状态。那样感觉太费劲了。
And now I would get jobs where I'm acting against people like you guys who have been doing it so long and I'd feel like I'm not good enough and their self-doubt would come in. Well, we'd be judging you, but... You should. And Sean would have a spare rope and chair for you if things went wrong. You know?
而且现在我接到的工作都是和你们这些经验丰富的人演对手戏，我会觉得自己不够好，开始自我怀疑。嗯，我们会评判你的，不过……你本来就该这样。如果事情搞砸了，肖恩还会为你准备一根备用绳子和一把椅子，你知道吗？
Always standing by. Always standing by. Yeah. Well, I think you could do whatever you wanted, and certainly now you could, but you probably always, I suspect you always could have. Yeah, leave yourself open for all of it, because you seem incredibly dynamic
随时待命。随时待命。是的。嗯，我认为你可以做任何你想做的事，当然现在你也可以，但你可能一直，我猜你以前也一直可以。是的，让自己对这一切都保持开放，因为你看起来非常有活力
and well-suited for all opportunities. Yeah, I'm so happy for your success. I wanna see you doing more stuff. You're so naturally funny and so funny. And what I also love about it is, well, maybe you do on some of your podcasts and stuff, but you don't seem to have fallen in the trap yet of a lot of stand-ups who seem to be obsessed
并且非常适合所有的机会。是的，我为你取得的成功感到由衷的高兴。我很想看你做更多的事情。你太有天生幽默感了，而且非常搞笑。我特别喜欢的一点是——也许你在某些播客里这样做过——但你似乎还没落入许多单口喜剧演员常犯的陷阱，他们似乎总是痴迷于
with talking about breaking down stand-up, which I'm like fucking enough. I'm so bored by it. Some of these older stand-ups, I'm like shut the fuck up, who cares? Who do you think you are? Who cares? Who the fucking cares?
谈论解构单口喜剧，我真是烦透了。我对此感到厌烦。其中一些老牌单口喜剧演员，我只想说闭上你们的臭嘴，谁在乎呢？你觉得自己是谁？谁在乎？谁他妈在乎？
What does that mean, breaking down stand-up? You mean like talking loud about it? Oh, the science behind it. No, the science behind it. What they think about stand-up? You mean like talking about it? No, the science behind it. What they think about stand-up and how they do it. And they only talk to other stand-up. I'm like, shut up, man. Don't apologize for a joke and cancel culture.
这是什么意思，剖析单口喜剧？你是说像大声讨论它吗？哦，背后的科学。不，是背后的科学。他们对单口喜剧的看法？你是说像讨论它一样？不，是背后的科学。他们对单口喜剧的看法以及他们是如何表演的。而且他们只和其他单口喜剧演员交流。我就想，闭嘴吧，老兄。不要为笑话和取消文化道歉。
I'm just really not that interested in that stuff either. And I think that we like to pat ourselves. And you know, every artist likes to pat themselves on the back. Like they change the world. And some of it does, but I just, I don't know. I don't... I kind of just fell into it and it fits me, but I don't think of it as stand-ups are like above other...
我也真的对那些东西没那么感兴趣。而且我觉得我们喜欢自我标榜。你知道的，每个艺术家都喜欢自我标榜，觉得自己改变了世界。有些作品确实做到了，但我只是，我不知道。我只是阴差阳错地走上了这条路，它挺适合我的，但我并不认为单口喜剧演员就比其他人高出一等……
I think sometimes we have to think that because we feel so less than, and that's why we do stand-up, is because we didn't fit in any of the other ones. I can see that, but like all of us are just out here trying to figure it out. And so when people start breaking it down as though we're a process and as though we're a science. Anyway. But when people ask me about the process, it's always like, how do you write it?
我想有时我们不得不这样想，因为我们觉得自己太渺小了，这就是我们做单口喜剧的原因，因为我们在其他地方都格格不入。我能理解，但我们所有人其实都在摸索。所以当人们开始把这一切剖析得像个流程、像门科学一样时……不管怎样。但当人们问我创作过程时，总是在问，你是怎么写的？
I think it's the same for most comedians. It's just you say something funny in conversation and then you go, oh, I should maybe do something about that. And then you take out your phone and the conversation comes to a halt and everyone waits For you and you go what wait exactly how did I say it? And then they tell you and then you ruin the moment
我想大部分喜剧演员都一样。就是在交谈中你说了句好笑的话，然后你会想，哦，我或许该把这个写进段子里。接着你掏出手机，谈话戛然而止，所有人都等着你，然后你问，等等，我刚才到底是怎么说的？接着他们告诉你，然后你就毁了这个气氛。
And then you and then I'm in the wings of the show before the show kind of going like what should I do tonight? I'm kind of sick of my act as it is like maybe I'll and I'll look through I go Okay, maybe I'll throw that in and it just kind of happens on stage, but it's it's it's a lazy room Right, but you're super funny. I'm doing the only thing I've ever been good at. You're the top of the game. Honestly, I could just watch you do stand up all the time. You're really awesome,
然后你，然后我在演出后台的侧幕条，在演出前那种状态，心里想着：“今晚我该演点啥？我对现有的表演有点腻了，也许我可以……”然后我翻翻笔记，心想：“好吧，也许我可以把这个加进去。”一切都是在舞台上临时发生的，但那是一个很松散的场子。不过你超级搞笑。我只是在做我唯一擅长的事。你是这个领域的顶尖高手。说实话，我真能一直看你演单口喜剧。你真的很棒，
and you're very generous to have come here. And someone who's been a fan, as long as I have to see you finally get this kind of recognition. It's awesome. Yeah, for sure. It's well, being on Smartless is a huge, it's a huge deal to me.
你能来到这里真的非常慷慨。作为一个这么久的粉丝，看到你终于获得这种认可，真是太棒了。是的，当然。能上Smartless对我来说是一件非常、非常了不起的事。
You guys are so... You've done a huge favor. Thank you. What a bunch of clowns. You guys are so fucking funny. Thank you. What a bunch of clowns. And your show was so good. And talk about vulnerability. I mean, that's, but that's what we, don't we all want that from our celebrities?
你们真是太……你们帮了大忙。谢谢。真是一群小丑。你们真他妈的太有趣了。谢谢。真是一群小丑。而且你们的演出太棒了。说到脆弱感，我的意思是，那是，但难道我们不都希望从我们的名人身上得到这些吗？
Like I've always just wanted to see how they are. I used to love the, like, the stars are just like us, kind of things. I used to really do love that. And that's what I think podcasts have given us, is that conversational quality, and we get to really do love that. And that's what I think podcasts have given us, is that conversational quality, and we get to really know you. And some actors stink,
就像我一直只是想看看他们是什么样子的。我以前很喜欢那种“明星就像我们一样”的栏目，我以前真的很喜欢那个。而我认为播客带给我们的正是这种对话般的品质，让我们能够真正了解你。而且有些演员真的很逊，
and they're not interesting at all in conversation. But you guys, you're so fucking funny. And yeah, I'm just like. You're infectious. You're very, very clean, honest sort of energy coming out of you is really kind of funny. We're droll in moments, you're funny. So.
而且他们在对话中一点意思也没有。但你们呢，你们太他妈搞笑了。而且，是的，我就是觉得……你们很有感染力。你们身上散发出的那种非常非常干净、诚实的能量真的挺好笑的。我们有时显得呆板，而你们很搞笑。所以就这样。
No, these are hilarious. All of you is really kind of fun. We're droll in moments, you're funny, so... Yeah. No, these are hilarious. All of you. Thanks, Nikki. It's so good to see you. So good to see you too. Thank you. Yeah, you too. Yeah, thanks, Nikki. Oh my God, Nikki Glaser! Nikki Glaser!
不，这些太搞笑了。你们所有人都挺有意思的。我们有时很滑稽，你们也很好笑，所以……对。不，这些太搞笑了。你们所有人。谢谢你，尼基。很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你。谢谢。对，我也是。对，谢谢你，尼基。天哪，尼基·格雷泽！尼基·格雷泽！
Thank you guys. Thank you, Nikki. Thanks, Nikki. Have a great rest of the day. Bye. Bye. How great is Nikki Glaser? That was super fun. I'm embarrassed to say that's my first experience. Have a great rest of the day. Bye. Bye. How great is Nikki Glaser? That was super fun.
谢谢大家。谢谢你，尼基。谢谢，尼基。祝大家今天剩下时间过得愉快。再见。再见。尼基·格拉泽太棒了吧？这真的超级有趣。我很不好意思地说，这是我第一次体验。祝大家今天剩下时间过得愉快。再见。再见。尼基·格拉泽太棒了吧？这真的超级有趣。
I'm embarrassed to say that's my first experience with her. And wow, what a form. Only my second. I'm a huge fan of hers already. Yeah, she's amazing. She's super, super amazing. I love what she said because she, I mean, even on here, she's just brutally honest about everything
我很不好意思地说，这是我第一次听她的歌。哇，这水平真是太高了。这只是我听的第二首。我已经成她的超级粉丝了。是的，她太棒了。她超级、超级棒。我特别喜欢她说的话，因为她，我是说，甚至在这个节目里，她对所有事情都直言不讳。
and how she feels and her opinions. And I think that's what people are drawn to. She's got specials on Netflix that I can like immediately pull up. She's got specials on HBO and Comedy Central. Dude, she's an absolute comedy megastar. Yeah, I really take him by her. And not just because of her level,
以及她的感受和她的观点。我认为这正是吸引人们的地方。她在网飞上有特辑，我可以马上搜到。她在HBO和喜剧中心也有特辑。老实说，她绝对是个喜剧巨星。是的，我对她印象真的很深刻。不仅是因为她的水准，
but just also how funny she is. She is profoundly funny, so good. And my buddy, great Bob Kastrone, used to work with her too. That's how he kind of really turned me on to her about five years ago. He was like, Nikki Glaser's the funniest. He wrote with her for a long time.
不仅如此，她还非常幽默。她真的是太有趣了，太棒了。我的好朋友、优秀的鲍勃·卡斯特罗也曾和她共事过。大约五年前，就是他让我真正开始关注她的。他当时说：“妮基·格拉瑟是最搞笑的。”他曾和她一起工作了很长时间。
And then she would be great in movies and she doesn't need to act. She'd be amazing. You know, it's like five people that act. Most of us just play versions of ourselves and I'd love to see a million different versions of her. Yeah, but she'd be great. I agree.
然后她演电影肯定也会很棒，而且她根本不需要演技。她会非常厉害。你知道的，真正会演戏的也就五个人吧。我们大多数人其实都只是在演自己不同的一面，我很想看她展现出一百万种不同的自己。对，但她一定会很棒。我同意。
No, she's a really nice, which is so funny because she does these roasts, which can be so super cutting and stuff, and she's actually like a super nice, kind person. And yeah, she's cool. Sean, do you have a body warm up? Sean, are you frozen? What's going on?
不，她其实人非常好，这很有趣，因为她做的那些吐槽秀可以非常尖锐，但她实际上是一个超级好、非常善良的人。是的，她很酷。肖恩，你有什么身体热身方法吗？肖恩，你卡住了吗？怎么回事？
It's just trying to shuffling through my ideas. It's so fucking, Sean, Sean. Look, I wasn't, I was just biding my time. Why would you waste it? Wait, yeah, did you just like barely float that one up there? You were like, all of a sudden you were having a coma. You were in a coma. And then you-
这只是在整理我的想法。这太他妈的了，肖恩，肖恩。听着，我不是，我只是在等待时机。你为什么要浪费它？等等，对，你刚才是不是随便抛出了那个想法？你就像是，突然之间你陷入了昏迷。你昏迷了。然后你——
No, I was bi-eating my time. Yeah, but- What's happening? Bi-eating my- Let's cut and re-roll. Let's do it. That's a good one. It's very good.
不，我当时在消磨时间。是啊，但是——怎么回事？消磨时——我们剪掉重来吧。干吧。这个挺好的。非常好。
It's great, but what if I threw- I wish you would have just owned it instead of apologized for it. Why didn't you just... You're just sitting there and we know this is Sean. He was looking at a list that he had on his computer of buys. Well, stand buys. Yeah.
这很棒，但如果我扔——我希望你能直接承认而不是道歉。为什么你不只是……你就坐在那里，我们都知道这是肖恩。他在看他电脑上的购物清单。嗯，常备货。嗯。
Oh, guys, I found one. Fucking fuck, what is happening? It's a nightmare. Will, can you take us out like we should? You got anything? Well... We just had two good ones. I actually do have a book of all the great buys that I want to use and I call it my buy BI-BALL!
哦，伙计们，我找到了一个。他妈的，到底怎么回事？简直是噩梦。威尔，你能像平时那样带我们离开吗？你有什么发现吗？好吧……我们刚找到两个不错的。我其实有一本记着所有我想买的好东西的笔记本，我把它叫作我的“买买球”！
Oh, okay. That'll do. We'll see you at the next one. Terry and Rob Armgerf. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
哦，好吧。那就这样。我们在下一个地方见。特里和罗布·阿姆格夫。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。